357 élèves ont perturbé la minute de
silence en hommage au professeur d'aras
doivent-ils être renvoyés sanctionnés
Gabriel Atal le ministre de l'Éducation
a été extrêmement dur là-dessus qui
pense que oui et qui pense que non et je
vous pose la question également chez
vous à 19h43 en direct tout le monde
pense que oui oui oui évidemment qu'il
faut les renvoyer parce que on parle pas
d'élèves qui ont souri ou qui ont toussé
pendant la minute de silence qui ont
dérangé il y a certains élèves et
apparemment beaucoup qui ont fait
l'apologie du terrorisme pendant cette
minute de silence donc on rigole pas
avec ça il faut des sanctions
exemplaires parce que en faisant
l'apologie du terrorisme ces élèves se
rendent complices de ces de ces de ces
drames et il y a peut-être
malheureusement même de potentiels
terroristes parmi ces élèves donc il
faut les sanctionner il faut frapper
fort et je trouve que c'est très bien ce
que fait Gabriel Atal parce qu'il prend
le problème à bras le cor et bravo à lui
renvoyé où excusez-moi excusez-moi les
renvoyer où combien de temps non mais
c'est intéressant parce que là il a fait
un effet je suis d'accord avec lui il
faut les sanctionner parce que c'est des
vermines de faire ça ça se fait pas mais
les renvoyer où en fait qu'est-ce qu'on
fait faut les sanctionner faut les
mettre dans des centres fermés faut les
mettre et là là après ça va aller
beaucoup mieux 170 enfants là il y a de
tout âge parce qu'
y 357 357 de tout ge il y a des petits
il y a des ados il faut conoquer les par
moi je suis d'accord je suis d'accord
mais quand quand j'entends le ministre
dire les renvoyer c'est très bien ils
bougent par rapport à l'autre ministre
qui foutait rien c'est très bien moi je
suis pour qu'on les renvoie 3 jours mais
après qu'est-ce qu'on fait en attendant
les les procédures disciplinaires donc
en fonction de la procédure
disciplinaire qui fera j'imagine du cas
par cas entre un élève qui a été pris
avec le groupe et qui bêtement parce
qu'il comprend pas du tout ce qui se
passe et qui a voulu faire le malin et
puis un qui fait vraiment une apologie
du terrorisme clair et
nette différ oui pour moi c'est la
sanction pour marquer le coup mais
effectivement rmon tu lu dis les
renvoyer où donc ils vont rester
peut-être 3 jours chez eux mais si ces
enfants sont comme ça c'est qu'ils ont
un terro familial et donc ils vont
encore plus se faire engrainer à la
maison peut-être même ils vont se faire
féliciter donc je pense qu'il doit y
avoir des cours d'éducation civique
encore plus renforcé des heures et des
heures par semaine pour apprendre aux
enfants ce qui n'apprennent pas à la
maison Jacques card c'est non parce que
je pense que ce serait plus constructif
pour la société et pour eux qu'il soi
contraint de prendre des cours sur le
conflit israëlo-palestinien de tout
comprendre de ce qui s'est passé depuis
47 ça va leur prendre un certain nombre
de semaines de ce qui s'est passé avant
aussi parce que c'est un conflit qui
prend des racines bien plus loin pour
les professeurs he oui mais je veux dire
on est dans un contexte ce que je veux
dire c'est qu'on est dans un contexte où
on perturbe par par mes connaissances et
par manque de savoir et par manque de
repère oui c'est c'est une façon aussi
de montrer aux professeurs qu'ils ne
sont pas seuls oui l'État leur dit on
est avec vous on vous laisse pas comme
on l' comme on l' pu le faire par le
passé on vous laisse pas tomber ce que
je veux dire c'est que la sanction que
réclame le ministre pour moi est 100 %
justifié je m'interroge juste sur juste
l'exclusion je suis d'accord avec ce que
dit Raymon je pense que ça devrait
s'accompagner de cours voilà de cours de
mais mais Jacques là vous faites dans
l'angélisme là on est sur des jeunes on
est sur des jeunes qui ont fait
l'apologie du terroriste purement et
simplement ils ont pas contesté ils ont
pas siléou et donc tu fais quoi tu les
enferes et tu attends que ça passe
definitivement sais du procureur et je
les condamne à
deutend apologie du terrorisme c'est 5
ans 5 ans de prison ils peuvent être
condamnés à la moitié excuse de minorité
à 2 ans et demi de prison moi je suis
pour qui la prison tu sais que le juge
il va accompagner cette décision et il
va probablement justement leur donner
des entre guillemets des travaux
d'intérêt général pas
cours de 10 ans dans le Lot si tu as un
petit de 10 ans ou 12 ans tu vas le
[__] en prison et tu fous plus jamais
à l'école le terroriste de vendred 20
ans 20 ans c'est un adolescent qui a 14
an quelques anné mais ce que je veux
dire c'est qu'ils sont à quelques années
potentiellement vous entendez parler que
tu fais à partir de 13 ans tu c'est ce
dont on parle sont des
enfants on parle pas d'une connerie à
Laé on parle de faire l'apologie du
terrorisme bien il faut leur apprendre
le erreur c'est
justement
dans le problème c'est pas l'enfant de
10 12 ans à qui on n pas expliqué que
quand on fait une de silence il faut
rester tranquille c'est les parents moi
je suis comme Jacques appelle les
parents convoque les parents prend des
sanctions par rapport aux parents Disle
il y a des règles ici peut-être des
cours d'éducation civisme tu fais des
choses mais de dire là comme ça il a 12
ans je veux qu'il aille en prison je
veux plus qu'il aille à l'école vous
croyez qu'il va faire quoi le petit à 12
ans dans la rue ça va être encore pire
vous avez une bombe dans les mains vous
mettez 150 combien avz d'enfants 157 357
enfants vous les sortez de l'école c'est
des bombes voilà c'est des bombes dans
la nature c'est pas comme ça qu'on
faitich moi je suis pour sur ont été
prévenus ils étaient prévenus avant que
s'il y avait des perturbations comment
êes pourquoi pour une exclusion
temporaire dur à dire il pas dit comme
ça une exclusion temporaire voilà ils
avaient été prévenus donc chacun savait
il était face à sa conscience chacun
savait que pendant la minute de silence
il fallait respecter la minute il y en a
qui ont décider il y en a qui ont dit
non je respecte pas jeis unmigrateur de
Ben Naden quand tu as 13 ans tu dis ça
c'est pas possible il
fautexion en a Mar de faire comme je
benen et je kiffe pas Mbappé ou je kiffe
pas un acteur de cinéma ou je kiffe pas
le
pas kiffe pas Samuel P KFF pas Samuel
Pat à 13 ans c'est que quand tu rentres
chez toi le soir le petit il entend des
trucs qu' devrait pas entend parents
c'est l'environnement c'est un truc qui
va ça ahurissant Raymon et Jacques pour
moi c'est ahurissant ici vous êtes sans
arrêt à dire notamment vous Raymond la
société a changé les enfants aujourd'hui
ont complètement changé mais non mais
vous êtes en train de dire on les met
pas en prison on les met en prison c'est
déjà fait une journée de prison toi
qu'est-ce
que j'ai pas fait l'apologie du
terrorisme je vous parle pas d'un petit
12 ans je vous parle à partir de
mais arrêtez vraiment arrêtez avec ça
l'apologie apologie du terrorisme ces
genslà ils sont contents qu'un
professeur exemplaire d'arace a été tué
vous vous rendez compte ce que vous
ditesr des
enfants c'est des lycéens des collégiens
il y en a qui ont 17 ans sais pas il y a
plusieurs il y a peut-être plusieurs
niveaux dans ce qu'ils ont fait de ce
qu'il pensent et de ce qu'il oui c'est
le procureur qui dir oui ben justement
et ben ensuite il y a une une décision
qui va être proportionnée avec un juge
qui va estimer ce qu'il doiv voilà entre
guillemets si ses enfants peuvent être
récupérables je veux dire on va pas
considérer que 350 gamins sont des
apprentis
terrorist non mais bien sûr qu'il faut
marquer les esprits mais en fait est-ce
qu'on peut récupérer des enfants si les
parents eux-mêmes sont irrécupérables
c'està-dire qu'on aura beau nettoyer le
cerveau d'enfants qui pensent des
horreurs abominables sur Al-Qaïda ou sur
daesh j'en sais rien et si par par
ailleurs ils sont instrumentalisés et le
soir quand ils rentent chez eux on leur
lave le cerveau avec d'autres idéologies
donc malgré tout moi je pense que
exactement comme RM je pense que la
prison ça sert à rien parce que une fois
qu'ils sort de la prison en fait
qu'est-ce qu'ils font ils retrouvent
dans ils retournent dans leur
environnement ils sont encore plus ils
sont encore plus on va dire radicalisé
en prison donc c'est catastrophique mais
je pense que malgré tout il faut marquer
le coup il faut convoquer les parents et
moi je pense qu' il faut qu'on soit très
très très ferme contre les parents mais
on s'étonne pas d'avoir des gamins de 17
ans ou 20 ans après qui poignirent des
profs sais je vais te dire une chose
tant par tant qu'on sanctionnera jamais
les parents et qu'on dira aux parents
c'est pas grave c'est un mineur on vous
bouche pas on vous laisse
tranquillee le version enfants il
continueront à dire moi je vais la
Marseillaise et ben moi je vais chier
sur les institutions Mo
r des parents à la place
des
question est
fa
fa fa
par
pris
pas s arê quand il y a des violences ici
vous me dites que je suis trop laxiste
là je dis vous avez raison
par parce que ça vous arrange pas du
tout vous êes écoutez-moi une seconde
vous êtes en train de légitimer
l'assassinat d'un
professeur vous rendez
pasteexqu tu sais ce qu'on fait avec les
enfants des de ceux qui ont fait du
djihad qui sont des Français qui sont
partis en Syrie est-ce que tu sais qu'on
fait avec eux tu sais que depuis 2 ans
et 3 ans il y a des centres de
déradicalisation elle en a parlé la
damier voilà bon ben dans ces centres on
il y a aucune image jamais personne n'a
pu tourner ce qui se passait dans ces
centres on récupère ses enfants il y a
peut-être des des adultes je n'en sais
rien mais depuis le temps il y a des
adultes il y a des adolescents qui sont
peut-être devenus 18 19 ans et qui sont
désormais adultes on essaie de faire en
sorte qu'il soit déradicalisé je pense
qu'il faut faire exactement la même
chose avec eux c'est pour ça que je
pense que ta solution qui consiste à les
enfermer pourquoi pas les mettre avec
des islamistes mais c'est une
B PL r toi tu es pour par tu peux
pourquoi tu ve pas sanctionner les par
j'aimis bien sanner par d'abord on a pas
le drit en France alors changer la loi
on peut pas sanctionner quelqu'un à la
place
de raison faut changer plein de lois
mais même moralement pour moi à partir
du moment où un enfant conteste la
tuerie d'aras terroriste c'est qu'il a
conceptualisé que dans sa tête tête il
est pour que ce professeur soit
assassiné je suis désolé donc à partir
de là c'est un danger pour la société il
doit être condamné à de la prison a si
simple que ça les parents lui et si ses
parents pensent la même chose que
lui par la différence entre un enfant la
différence entre un enfant et un adulte
c'est que un enfant peut continuer de
lui apprendre on peut on peut lui
apprendre dans un autre contexte on peut
peut-être que peut-être qu'il a eu une
mauvaise éducation peut-être qu'il a été
totalement entre guillemets embrigadé
quand on regarde la famille de celui qui
a commis cet horrible ass aras on
s'aperçoit que la petite la sœur
notamment la jeune sœur elle dit que
elle avait une obligation de ses frères
de mettre le voile des 11 ans de d'aller
dans une école religieuse enfin je veux
dire il y a eu un enfermement donc
peut-être que ces enfantsl entre
guillemets on pe les récupérer bien sûr
ils sont fautil sanctionner les parents
Gil monsieur non moi je dis non parce
que vous partez du principe que les 357
enfants vivent dans un environnement
familial où on fait aussi l'apologie du
tourisme tuen sa absolument rien qu' va
Fall faire 3 et on
vérifie vérifie peut-être qu' a 100 qui
sont suspect peut-être qu'il a 100
familles suspect ben on vérifie et
encore une fois le terroriste de
vendredi dernier c'est un gamin il a 20
ans aujourd'hui il y a des jeunes qui
ont des gamins mais bien sûr en a qui
ont 16 ans en a qui ont 16 ans qui
commettent des crimes aujourd'hui est-ce
que tu as envie est-ce que tu envie Sner
est-ce que tu as envie de sanctionner
les parents du terrorisme de vendredi tu
as envie de
Sner pases pas de voir ces me là ont
auourd'hui des attent arrêtez de croire
que les mecs ont 20 ans des fois
j'entends des mecs il a 17 ans c'est un
gamin à 18 ans c'est un gamin non tu vas
travailler à 18 ans
20 quand tu fais des enfants tu es
responsable de ton enfant jusqu'à sa
majorité c'est pas en fait un enfant et
il va aller brûler des voitures oui mais
il a 12 ans il savait pas non il savait
pas c'est à toi de lui expliquer qu'on
brûle pas des voiture si tu sais pas
éduquer ton enfant alors nous on va on
va te tenir par un autre moyen quel que
soit le moyen je vais trouver un moyen
de te sanctionner pour t'explique à ton
enfant qu'on fait pas de la merde ici et
qu'on siffle pas et qu'on eu pas et
qu'on crache pas sur les institutions
l'école et qu'on s'use pas êre content
quand un prof se fait tuer je vais
l'exliquer moi je vais trouver
je vous passez vot tour là vous passez
vot tour vous êtes en train de dire on
ne condamne pas et plus tard on fera une
mais vous êtes enfin c'est l'apologie
vous savez ce que c'est apologie du
terrorisme c'estàdire que il dit mais
non mais c'est fou ce que
j'entends moi que je
suis début à la fin en de N dire que des
gamins de 10 ans tu
vas 13 à 17 je suis désolé ils savent
très bien ce qu'ils font ce sont des
dangers pour la société il faut les
écarter en fait ce que tu comprends pas
ce que tu comprends pas ce que Ron vient
de dire là on parle d'enfants donc des
enfants sont sous la responsabilité des
par donc on ne regarde pas les enfants
on regarde les parents vu que quand tu
es tu es parent tu as des devoirs
c'est-à-dire d'emmener dans dans les
meilleures conditions tes enfants au
minimum jusqu'à la majorité en fait
c'est tout simplement que s'ils font des
des erreurs jusque là c'est les parents
qui moi je dire qui en faisant
por-emonnaie déjà une Amand c'est déjà
bien et c'est facile à faire et ça met
de l'argent dans les caisses vais te
dire quelque chose excuse-moi de te dire
ça parce que je t'aime beaucoup euh tu
es encore à côté de la plaque non mais
là si tu es encore à côté de la plaque
je suis désolé parce que non non non si
non non mais mais t-toi
Jean-Michel non non mais mon Gilou mon
Gilou je vais te dire le les seuls qui
peuvent avoir encore une petite autorité
ou une petite influence sur ses enfants
ce sont les parents donc si tu vas pas
taper au porte-monnaie des parents ou tu
vas pas sanctionner les parents sache
qu'il ne se passera Ren 3 mois donc là
Gilles une fois de plus excuse-moi et tu
es vraiment un garçon très sympathique
mais et et tu sers au débat mais tu es
toujours à mon avis à côté de la plaque
monchilou et je pense que tu es
rétrograde en fait tu as des idées des
années 80 alors qu'on est en en 2023 et
que la société a énormément changé et
sache-le tu te trompes complètement et
mettre des enfants de 10 ans en
prison ans c'est ça par contre je vais
te dire tu te trompes aussi il faut les
seul c'est pas la prison qui va les
changer
contraire contraire au contraire et et
ils vont devenir des héros en plus tu
vois on direa il été en prison tu vois
parce que c'est à cet âge là tu vois ça
fait c'est normal tu vois tu fais le CAH
tu par contre en revanche si leurs
parents sont sanctionnés tu vas voir que
là ça va pas du tout être la même
limonade donc une je pense g que tu te
trompes enc une fois ésolé te dire ça
mais c'est vrai que tu es toujours sur
la bande d'arrê d'urgence déci mais
c'est pas ça c c'est que j'entends ce
que vous dites mais ce n'est pas
possible
donc nut plus
entend ce disentous les G ceend
dis
cher va mieux attendre et changer lo ut
enants plutô que de faire ce que tu dis
lesvoyer en prison tu disours sur les
fich dis
fairees jour j'ai un coup téléphone du
commissariat votre fils fait des
conneries cette les pneus de deux trois
voitures dans la rue je sais pas ce qu'
lu a appris d'aprs ave ses copains ils
ont piquolé j'en sais rien une grosse
connerie heureusement ils m'ont pas
sanctionné j'éta pour rien je lui ai
jamais dit d'All crev les pneus j'ai
jamais fait de conneries
comm AEL qui nous dit sur Twitter AX qui
nous dit pas le déodorant l'omme qui
nous dit sir Lero familial je'y crois
pas trop plus jeune j'étais dans une
mouvance d'ultra droite et pourtant ma
famille est de gaucheta seul dans mon
délire et mes idées peut
fin financi
ça c'est vrai sanctionner financièrement
les parents mais je pense qu'il y a un
endoctrinement qui fait que si on sort
un enfant et on le punit juste cet
enfant ça se trouve ce sont des parents
qui ont plusieurs enfants donc je pense
qu'il vaut mieux taper à la racine
c'est-à-dire aux parents comme ça ça
évitera peut-être qu'ils enendoctrin
encore l' n'empêche pas l'autre l'
n'empêche pas l'autre aujourd'hui à
chaque fois qu'il y a un attentat qui
est perpétré on se pose la question
est-ce que ça aurait pu être évité que
va-t-on dire si dans 3 4 5 ans il y a un
jeune de 17 20 22 ans qui commet un
attentat et on se dit bah tiens ce jeune
avait
des propos qui faisa l'apologie du
terroriste pendant une minute de silence
et ben on aura bien l'air con
me je prison prison il faut les mettre
hors de nuir hors de nuir le terroriste
c'est pas crever les pneus d'un pote
c'est pas une connerie qu'on fait à la
récré c'est
grave les me si vous savez pas arrêtez
de dire devant la télé comm ça au G
prison et ben tu veux faire
quoi mec les mec la prison c'est pas
c'est pas le club M vous la prison parce
qu' on a jamais mis une journée en
prison moi j'ai fait juste de la garde à
vue déjà faites déjà de la garde à vue
vous allez voir ce que
c'est mais je l'ai pas fait bien sûr que
non je l'ai pas fait mais 13 ans
qu'est-ce que tu vas mettre un gamin de
13 ans 300 gamins 13 ans en prison ils
vont ressortir ils vont rencontrer des
gens en prison mais vous êtes
complè de 1 ans alors moi je don un
autre exemple demain moi mon F il a 1
ans il y a un mec qui est en train deer
la Marseillaise ou qui est en train deer
un prof mon fils il fait pareil pour
faire rire alors que je l'ai bien élevé
mais pour faire une VAN il fait pareil
en prison Marse pas terror par l'APIE du
terroriste pour faire rire son
copain vouu faireire
COP on convoque on ESS sair pour je dis
juste une chose par des ces de
déradicalisation on entend pas beaucoup
parler sera peut-être une solution
effectivement prendre ses enfants et
déconstruire ce qu'on le ce qu'on leur a
appris tu es pas
contre on parle pas de prison là on
accompagne les
enfantion cétait moi si j'avais la rage
et je prononce des des paroles qui sont
horribles comme ça et qu'on fout mes
parents une grosse encore plus ils ont
fait mes parents encore plus
le on comprendrait ce que vous dit on
par M mon père il m' jamais levé la main
jamais tapé moi jamais m'a tapé une fois
une fois j'ai pris l'argent d'une sortie
scolaire j'ai pris l'argent d'une sortie
scolaire ils ont appelé mon père au
travail ils ont dit venez tout de suite
votre père il a volé à l'école faut
rembourser il est arrivé dans une colère
impossible parce qu'il on prend au
porteemal il est arrivé il m'a giflé
dans la cour devant tout le monde il
m'avait jamais tapé mais le jour où on
lui a pris de l'argent il m'a tapé
est-ce que tu crois pas et plus jamais
j'ai recommencé donc à un moment donné
quand tu es un petit quand tuas un petit
trou du cul parce que c'est comme ça que
ça s'appelle si tes parents B si ça
s'appelle pas trop du cul ça s'appelle
terroriste mer
et que tes parents il font pas de boulot
derrière et ben il faut faut taper sur
les parents faut expliquer aux parents
que tu es là pour élever ton fils ou ta
fille c'est pas une garderie ici on fait
pas ce qu'on veut mais c'est trop trou
du cul en fait ça fait tu le
dédoin vous voulez que je vous donne la
définition de TR du mais je déoine pas
des verm c'est beaucoup plus que ça ex
la France il execr les professeurs il ex
ils execre nos valeurs et malgré tout je
pense que c'est quand même très très
grave il faut le signaler je pense qu'il
faut qu'il soit enfermé dans des C
nèique grave avec de l'endoctrinement et
voilà et on peut pas laisser passer ce
truc comme si de rien nétait Tai jamais
vu aussi mais non mais pour Samat avait
eu 793 actes en 2020 44 exclusions
définitives c'est rien et regardez là ça
continue on est passé de 179 à 357 à la
fin on en aura combien si on ne SVIT pas
aujourd'hui les gens se moquent de toi
pauvre procureur 357 s'il vous plaît
s'il vous plaît oh 357 enquête sur des
enfants déjà que tous les ét surchargés
dans les tribunaux imaginez-vous les les
délais non mais ils ils ont pas tort
compre tu vas faire 357 enquêes il
suffit qu' en a un qui devienne
terroriste en ai un qui devien un moment
un moment non plus il faut pas non plus
rêver les gars un moment je veux bien
qu'on a fasse des annonces de fou et
qu'on dise on va tout faire et on va on
va toutir faire les mecs aujourd'hui
vous croyez vraiment que ils vont
entendre 350
un par ave les famill mais je crois que
les me vous rendez pas compte le
problème que vous avez tous ici sur
différents sujets c'est que vous êtes
persuadé que la France peut tout faire
la France peut aider tout le monde la
France peut changer les lois très vite
la France peut mettre 357 personnes en
prison du jour au lendemainut que vous
sachiez un truc non non mais il faut que
vous sachiez un truc non mais c'est un
exemple Valéri ben pas de bêtises je
vous le dis aujourd'hui la France n'a
pas les moyens de ses ambitions bien
sûrteêes dans pays quiut tout fa
aujourd'hui la France c'est pas c'est
les gars c'est pas la France des années
des années des années 70 Ann 80 je
disprs la pas la même non plus oui
exactement bien s aujourd'ui 357 tu sais
dans quel état est la justice
aujourd'hui tu crois vraiment qu'on va
avoir 357 procès les gars mais vous êtes
des fou ex
pas
ure pvre procureur je je sais pas va êre
procure
je ça va des années les enants ils
seront jugés 45 ans je vous
disverisur contest des famill a F
ouou bien sûr ça oui exact 77 % oui pour
la sanction
voilà parents ex donc bravo voilà voyez
pasoui mais moi je suis complètement
d'accord avec vous encore et une fois
plus vous êtes contre la viis de de
Gilles Verdes qui est toujours sur la
bande d'arrêt d'urgence des idées mais
qu'on aime bien quand même on va se
rrouver